I'm going to start with congratulations
on the movie uh I'm I hope it's a huge
hit for you and for obviously Sony um
but I'm I'm a ton of questions I'm
curious you obviously got permission
from the estate to do to show so many
things that I was surprised you got to
include but was there a limit where they
said you can't do that
um it was a push and pull you know they
Anthony mccartan wrote the script you
know with the permission of the estate
and he had a lot of stuff in there
um there was a little bit of a
difference between them reading it in
print and seeing it fleshed out and and
um there were emotional reactions that
had to be navigated and uh there was a
balance that had to be struck but I
really commend them for
their commitment to kind of telling a
truthful story into including including
things that they were perhaps
uncomfortable with you know
um but yeah it was an it was it was a
navigation it was a negotiation it was a
balancing act and I'm sure the
negotiation possibly also uh went into
the editing room which is where I wanted
to talk about because that's ultimately
where it all comes together so did you
have a much longer cut was there talk a
little bit about how you found the run
time yeah we uh we started off at four
hours and 16 minutes was the first
editor's cut and so yeah there was a lot
of material just a lot of material and
and honestly
balancing the tone of the film went all
the way until the last minute of the
edit balancing the music in the film
what songs were going to be included
almost in in totality and and which
we're going to hear in Snippets that was
a balancing act and how much of which
relationship we're seeing
um you know it was all it was a big
process to kind of get it to the run
time than it is and then we refined that
run time uh you know up until the last
minute for people that just heard you
say four hours 16 minutes we need to
clarify that that's like literally
everything and not a movie meant to be
watched well no right exactly what was
the cut that you were really happy with
the length of the cut that you're like
oh this is pretty good was it like two
and a half hours was it three hours yeah
there there was a two hour and
27 minute cut that I loved a lot
and there was a two hour and 36 minute
cut that I loved a lot is there for fans
of Whitney who eventually on Blu-ray
home video is there any chance of you
releasing the deleted scenes or doing an
Extended Cut absolutely the deleted
scenes will be released 100 so one of
the things that I found when I was
reading about the the making of the
movie is that um you obviously had to
film multiple different time periods on
the same day just due to budget and
filming schedule and what is that like
trying to depict like three different
periods of Whitney's life on the same
day because it's a challenge for any
actor on to deliver a performance for
one time period you know what I mean let
me tell you about naomiac you know she
and she's she's a phenomenal actor but
this is one it's actually one of my
favorite things it's because it's really
working with the actor on the continuity
and and you know reminding ourselves
where we are in the film but they let me
tell you two things that she did she did
very very early in her career a scene um
with Robin where they're you know their
kids and and you know at the rec center
and entering rehab on the same day
yeah that's crazy but here's my favorite
uh and it really it's really stayed with
me
when Clive says uh you need rehab that
beautiful scene
that was Stanley Tucci's first day of
work
can you imagine that was their first
scene together but when you have truly
gifted actors uh you know really a great
artists you're they're able to create
and to find a relationship that feels
lived in
and um being present for that and
participating in that uh it's it's one
of my favorite things thank you so much
for uh talking with me I do hope the
film's a huge hit for you
um thank you so much for your time thank
you